nobody I would rather be working with in
the world than this person and there
wasn't one moment of tension in all
those years unless you're not telling me
was there something that you felt no
there's we literally delighted in the
possibility of what we've got to do
every single day I wish I could still do
it you do yeah I never wanted to leave
the character she was the most
delightful and the people that we got to
be did you feel that way when we
finished
it's heart-wrenching to not be in the
world so thank you for bringing us back
here today the characters stick with you
yeah well
it depends on how you you know how much
you let let them
appreciate your your being but yeah uh
yeah aspects certainly aspects of them
do stay with you I wish I had a little
bit more Rose in me because sometimes I
feel like I kind of walk through life
with more apology than I think she does